con edades comprendidas entre los 22 y
los 36 meses dos de los cuatro niños
heridos en el ataque con cuchillo del
jueves en Nancy siguen en estado crítico
son víctimas muy jóvenes no soy médico
pero nos han dicho que su salud sigue
siendo extremadamente frágil
unas y ha sido traslado a Ginebra los
otros tres que fueron operados en Nancy
han sido trasladados ahora a grenor
hospitalizar el presidente francés y su
esposa llegaron al Hospital
Universitario de Google para visitar a
las víctimas y a sus familias dos
adultos también resultaron heridos en el
ataque detenido el jueves casi
inmediatamente después del echó el
comportamiento del sospechoso bajo
custodia se ha descrito como agitado
según la fiscalía de ansi se trata de un
solicitante de asilo sirio nacido en
1991 que entró legalmente a Francia a
finales del 2022 las autoridades aún
intenta n comprender los motivos de su
ataque y ya declararon que no hay ningún
móvil terrorista aparente antes de
apuñalar los niños en el parque infantil
El atacante pronunció en inglés las
palabras en nombre de Jesucristo